producing laws is not an easier problem
than producing cars or food so if the
government's incompetent to do a good
job of producing cars and food why do
you expect it to do a good job music
legal system within which you are then
gonna produce the cars time Paul fine
with reason TV
we're here at Liberto Pia in San Diego
California and we're talking with David
Friedman a scholar at the Santa Clara
University Law School and economist and
author a novelist and of course the son
of Milton Friedman welcome thanks for
being with us David thank you you've
probably been asked us about ten
thousand times over the last I guess 40
years of your life what is
anarcho-capitalism and how do you
differentiate between that version of
anarchism err anarchy and other sort of
more leftist conceptions the term
anarchy gets used by a variety of
different people in different ways but I
would have said that for the ones who I
would say really our anarchists on the
left
the real problem is what economists call
the coordination problem that you have a
society with many millions of people
doing anything requires the cooperation
of a large number of those people
somebody's got to harvest the food turn
the food into cereal deliver it to you
get the milk etc etc and how do you
coordinate them for the
anarcho-capitalism version is you just
expand the way we coordinate things a
little bit farther to include the things
government now does so that you have in
effect law and law enforcement and
dispute arbitration and such produced on
the market the same way cars and food
are that it seems to me is a much more
believable story than to say that
somehow people in an unexplained way
will coordinate their activity to
produce everything right oftentimes
libertarians will talk to Anna
anarcho-capitalists and they'll they'll
butt heads and such what what to your
mind is sort of the difference between a
sort of libertarian conception of the
way society should work in
anarcho-capitalists I would have said
that anarcho-capitalism is one form of
libertarianism that we sometimes
distinguish anarchists from men are
kists meaning people who want not much
government but some and the fundamental
problem with America's position I think
and this was the way I started my talk
today
is that they believe that governments
are incompetent to produce food and cars
and housing and stuff and therefore the
right way to run a society is by private
property and trade under a framework of
laws that make all that possible
but they're then relying on the
government to produce that framework of
laws producing laws is not an easier
problem than producing cars or food so
if the government's incompetent to do a
good job of producing cars and food why
do you expect you to do a good job of
producing the legal system within which
you are then gonna produce the the cars
in the food what did your father make of
your sort of anarchists leanings I think
basically his view was that the
institutions I described might work but
probably wouldn't and my view was they
might not work but probably would so it
wasn't a very sharp disagreement can you
point to a particular kind of era or
time and place in history where you'd
had some sort of an approximation of an
anarcho-capitalist regime or are there
indications say even in privatization
movements today where you see bubble
sort of a bubbling up of these ideas
elements of existed in many societies I
don't have any full blown version one of
the societies I discussed in the book in
the second edition is saga period
Iceland and that was a society where
there was a legal system there was a
court system those were both government
so to speak but there was no executive
arm of government so once you got your
verdict you had to enforce it and that
was an example of what I would describe
as a feud system the feud system is
basically a decentralized rights
enforcement system where the sort of
simple version of a feud system is you
do something wrong to me I threatened to
use violence against you and the society
is so organized that that threat is much
more effective if you really did do
something wrong than if you didn't
element that huge system exists today if
you think about things like the patent
fights going on in the high-tech world
that's sort of a feud system where I'm
not going to tacky with guns are gonna
attack you with lawyers but we're in a
sense what keeps you from attacking me
is the fact that that I'll attack you if
you do there's a very interesting book
by Robert Alexson who's a Yale Law
professor called order without law which
describes in modern-day America a few
hours from where I live an area where
part of the legal rules ignores the laws
of California and are based on local
community norms and they're really
enforced by private actions so I think
features of what I described have
existed in lots of contexts but I don't
think the full-blown version has existed
anywhere one of the things that strikes
me as interesting about sort of
restitution based legal systems is that
sort of magically victimless crimes
disappear is that an attractive an
aspect or what do you think about that
I'm not sure that restitution is the
essential feature because you could
imagine an anarcho-capitalist society
there might be some crimes where it
wasn't practical to make people pay
damages and you therefore had to execute
them or lock them up or something else
instead it is unlikely that I will be
willing to pay as much to keep you from
using drugs as you were willing to pay
to be able to use drugs if you want to
use drugs and ditto for all the other
victimless crimes and therefore it would
be surprising they're not impossible if
such a market generated such laws but it
could if you imagine if people's
feelings are strong enough that's why I
like to say that anarcho-capitalism is
not by definition libertarian that that
anarcho-capitalism is libertarian is a
prediction not a definition the last
question I have for you you've been
around this movement for a long time if
you know libertarian ideas are in one
dimension much more popular than ever
before what many young people are being
turned on by these ideas Ron Paul has
become a hero to many people your father
is a you know a hero to many more people
every year it seems at the same time our
governments in trouble Europe's in
trouble
what are you optimistic about the future
what do you make of the current trends I
think that usually everything is things
are going in both directions at once
that things are getting better in some
ways and worse than others is the usual
pattern is also true internationally
that the really big positive trend I
think is China in India and that not
that they are very libertarian but they
are much more free market than they were
30 or 40 years ago and are becoming much
richer as a result and I think most
people can see the writing on the wall
for that so that the story that was
widely accepted in the 1960s which is
that the only way poor countries are
gonna get rich is to have a strong
central government and central planning
and Trevor
lots of foreign aid is much less
believable now than it was then the good
part about things like the present
European problems is that governments
may run out of money and when
governments run out of money there
sometimes willing to consider selling
off government firms and becoming more
private that that might happen when you
can hope but it might go the other way I
think it would be a disaster if Europe
became one country which is the other
direction things are pushing towards
with the EU problems I think competition
is a good thing for countries I think
probably the u.s. is too big it might be
better off if we were at 8 or 10
different countries assuming they had a
reasonable degree or free trade we're
fighting each other and similarly I
think one of the virtues of Europe at
the moment is that to a considerable
extent the countries are competing with
each other thank you very much David for
reason TV I'm Paul fine
[Music]